- [Voiceover] Let's build our
intuition for visually adding
and subtracting vectors.
So let's say that I have
vector a, and I add that
to vector, to vector b,
and the resulting vector is a vector c,
is vector c.
So what could this look like visually
if we assume that a, b and c
are two-dimensional vectors?
Well, I'm just going to draw
what vector a might look like.
So let's say that this
right over here is vector a,
and vector b, vector b,
since I'm adding it to
vector a, I'm going to put
its initial point at the
terminal point of vector a,
and then I'm going to draw vector b.
So let's say vector b looks like that.
So that is vector b, let me label these.
That is vector a, this is vector b.
And I did that so that I can
figure out what the sum is,
what vector c is going to be.
So that is vector b,
and what would that be?
Well, we would start at the
initial point of vector a
and then go to the
terminal point of vector b.
So this right over there
would be the sum.
So that would be vector
c right over there.
So the important realization
is if I add two vectors,
I would put the tail of one
at the head of the other.
And now what's neat
about this if I'm adding,
the order doesn't matter.
I could've done this the other way around.
I could've started with vector b.
I could've said vector b plus vector a
is equal to vector c,
and you could see that visually.
It would be a slightly
different visual diagram
but you get to the same place.
So if I start with vector b,
let's say I start over here,
In fact, you don't have
to start at the origin
but let's say that was the origin.
So I could start with
vector b, draw vector b
just like that, and
then add vector a to it.
So start vector a at the
terminal point of vector b,
and then go to (mumbles)
just draw vector a.
So vector a.
So once again, a vector,
I can shift them around
as long as I'm not changing the direction
or their magnitude.
So vector a looks like that.
And notice, if you now go and
start at the initial point
of b and go to the terminal
point of a, you still get
vector c.
So that's why a plus b and b
plus a are going to give you
the same thing.
Now what if instead of saying a plus b
I wanted to think about what
a minus b is going to be?
So let me write that down.
Vector a minus vector b, minus vector b.
And let's call that vector d.
That is equal to vector d.
So once again, I could start with vector a
and here, order matters.
So vector a looks something like this.
this is hand-drawn so it's not going to be
completely perfect.
So vector a, just like that.
And one way of thinking
about subtracting vector b
is instead of adding vector
b the way we did here,
we could add negative b.
So negative b would
have the same magnitude
but just the opposite direction.
So that's vector a.
Vector negative b will
still start right over here,
but will go in the opposite direction.
So let's do that.
So negative b is going to look like this,
is going to look something like this.
So that is negative b.
Notice, same magnitude
exactly opposite direction.
We've flipped it around 180 degrees,
and now the resulting
vector is going to be d.
So vector d is going to look like that,
vector d.
So c is a plus b, d is a minus b.
Or you can even call this
a plus, a plus negative b.
Now with that out of the
way, let's draw some diagrams
and go the other way.
See if we could go from the diagrams
to the actual equations.
So let's start with, let
me draw an interesting one.
So let's say that this...
Let's say that's vector a.
Vector a.
I'll use green.
Let's say that, that is vector b,
and I will now use magenta.
And let's say that this is vector c.
Vector c.
So I encourage you to pause the video
and see if you can write an equation
that defines this relationship.
Well, this is interesting
because they're all going
in a circle right over here.
Let's say that you started at...
This is your initial point.
You said, okay, a plus b,
well, if you're trying to
figure out what a plus b
is going to be, the resulting
vector would start here
and end here.
But vector c is going in
the opposite direction.
But we could, instead of thinking
about vector c like this,
we could think about the
opposite of vector c,
which would do,
so instead of calling this
c, I could flip this around
by calling it this negative c.
So I could flip this around,
and now, let me do the same color,
this would be equal to negative c.
Notice, before I just had vector c here
and it started at this point
and ended at this point.
Now I just flipped it
around, it has the exact
opposite direction, same magnitude.
Now it is negative c.
And this makes it easier for
us to construct an equation
because negative c starts at
the tip, at the initial point
or the tail of vector a,
and it goes to the head
of vector b or the
terminal point of vector b.
So we can now write an equation.
We could say vector a plus vector b,
plus vector b,
is equal to, is equal to not c,
it's equal to the negative of vector c.
So hopefully, you found that interesting.